welcome back to pjj design this is PJ a
lot of time if you have some bright cut
next to the stone or underneath the
stone it's going to make your stone look
brighter in your jewelry design today
I'm going to show you the technique how
to do this fancy cut to bright up your
gemstone in your jewelry care design
with Rhino 3D software are you ready
let's get started
[Music]
before we start working on it this type
of a setting I've been using in many of
my videos so I'm not going to repeating
there and if you are interest in
download a stone to use you are welcome
to sign up the newsleter and so you can
get a free uh Stone model there now the
second things I want to mention is we do
have this hor shape in the real world it
will have the graveyard cutting into
this triangle area so we try to mimic
that Engraving cut there in this model
so we're going to starting with this
setting is already arranged for the
three prong setting and have a stone
setting in place and then we are going
to create its heart now coming into the
side structure wise I'm going to draw a
hard shape a small outline and then
going to coming over
here giving a very
general shape of a heart there and then
you can always adjust if you feel feel
like that's not ideal you can moving
those control point to make it into the
shape that you like all right and then
the second thing is I need to somehow
giveing some sort of the thickness there
and uh but that's making into the hard
shape first we want to uh coming into
the mirror type it zero and having
something like that and also we wanted
to trim each other for the extra there
and also the extra there okay and that's
join it depends on how thick you want it
to have your border we're going to
offset this guy and coming inside a lot
more and I may want to have 1.5 and see
how that goes all right so maybe this
need to be talking a little bit more and
before we continue our design we Al
always wanted to check if overall size
is correct so uh right here in between
here and here is 8 mm and and see if
that is the size you want to be before
you continue to working on all right so
what I like to do is kind of uh scale it
down a little bit more because we
actually not exactly going to use those
two curve we're going to use their
offset and I will show you why okay so
I'm going to hiding this guy right here
all right so this is the shape we are
going to work with and you may want to
have in size a little bit rounder but we
can adjust that later um at this point I
need to figure out how many section do I
want it to have and for this one I'm
going to have a smaller section so it
will go quicker on the
demonstration so let me exploded this
guy and actually join back just half of
them so then we have two curve you can
always
rebuild if you feel like the curve is
not uh exactly what you want so let's
say we want to have 10 here and we want
to rebuild to the 10 uh make sure that
degree is three there or another way you
can make it smoother is by using the
command
smooth and then you can twg it by moving
those Point uh moving this uh bar up and
down right or left to get it smoother or
something like that okay so now this is
what we want I want to Define how many
section that I need so I'm going to use
a command
divide and I want to divide it in to
maybe um a
section so you're going to see the point
of the eight over there and we're going
to do it one more time we want to do a
section there and those are the
guideline for us so if I have a line in
between go from point to the point and I
will simply get the line something like
this
so I'm going to uh locking everybody
beside the point uh the line there that
we have so it's easier for us to take a
look on it now if I want to turn on all
the control point on this one and on
every
other straight line I'm going let's take
a look on the side I'm going to have
them go up somewhere like this
and then on the other side we are going
to pick up this point and every other
point
there and this one too going to go up
somewhere similar like this so those is
going to be the guideline for us to play
with that's starting with the first one
going snap into the end point end point
and end point there so then I have a
triangle
there but where is my rail to sweep it's
going to be between here and here and
here and
here all right so let's give it a try we
are going to do sweep to rail and you
got rail one rail two and this is your
crosssection and you will get that first
cut there and if we using the command
cap and then this will become a Polish
solid surface so the same idea is going
to apply on all of them so we're going
to snap in here and here coming back
with the straight line and we're going
to draw another line right
there and that's using the sweep to rail
you got rail one rail two
crosssection and something like
this now you may notice that this is a
huge uh straight line there and the
shape it's not really
follow the um the heart shape and that's
why we are going to triming later for
this demonstration I'm making the a but
in fact I will making more double so
that way you will get a smaller cut and
that will fitting into the outline
better so I'm going to speed speed it up
here
and we're going to use the cap command
for all of them right so the very last
one I did that way you can actually
split all of this in half so that way
you can meet at this point like what I
did there if that work better for you
you can uh work like that way and we are
missing one over here so I'm going to
again making half of it by drawing this
triangle there and we are going to use
the Swip to rail rail one rail two and
crosssection all right so we get
something like that again we want to use
the cap command to close it so now we
have all of them all we need to do is
select all the um poly
surface and we want to mirror to the
other
side and something like that so let's
unlock those original curv curve so
let's pick up those curve and we want to
join
them and let me turn them into the red
color easier for you to see okay so if
you do like this faet and that's fine
but I do want them to uh the ages lot
more smoother so it won't catch their
hair or something like that so what I
like to do is I want to cut it in a
little bit so that is going to come in
offset the curve for this the maybe uh3
mm so that way I will cut all the sharp
corner there this one I just need to uh
come in just a little bit maybe1 mm and
then you got something there okay so now
with those two new curve we are going to
the solid extruded planner curve and go
straight like this okay so that is a new
shape there all we need to do is bring
up and then uh I want a bowling
intersect which mean all of this shape
and the this shape it's going to
intersect and it will cut the extra off
so now we have a clear line
there this one I do want it to have some
sort of a thickness so let's bring back
the stone and see if the size is fitting
well and we can move a stone down a
little
bit something over there okay so it look
really nice and tight on the design and
then we're going to click on this curve
and this curve one more
time and then we want to extrude it this
time we want to extrude it going down uh
on the bottom as long as you cover where
the prong and the coola and make sure
your coola is not sticking out like that
all right so I'm going to bring in
somewhere there okay so this will be the
botton and um to support our Stone and
protect the stone tip there but I just
it's a little bit too much metal and
it's look really um heavy which going to
cost you something in the production so
I'm going to creating a
box with this box just coming into the
middle and going to move it down a
little
bit like
this and simply rotate a 45° there right
so that will be my color and I also want
to making a duplication
there and that can be any angle that
look nice to you so somewhere it's going
to be something like this maybe a little
bit longer in this case because I do
want to reduce the weight of the metal
that saved me some money on the
production all right so and then this
one I'm going to mirror to the other
side like
that okay so all we need to do is
bowling difference this botton with the
square that we just creating so that
will creating the opening there and if
that opening that that you see the
bottom of you know the setting there we
simply just going to trim it one more
time or bowling difference one more time
and this time we want to move this just
a little bit above the opening we just
made and with this setting
there we want it to be bowling
difference from this guy here okay so
that way we will have this let's take a
look on the render View and that's how
we going to have this earring I hope
this video give you some inspiration to
do your jewelry cat design and I have a
lot more trick and tip I wanted to share
with you if you are beginner to the jury
cat design I have a stone setting mini
course it's completely free for you in
this course I will discuss the basic
Stone setting knowledge and how to
create a prong set like the one in the
video and show you how to alterate into
your own custom design it's completely
free so check out the link at the
description below and I hope you to see
you in the course thank you for watching
and I'll see you next
oh